foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
ER he faced some of the best home run
hitters in the game won three World
Series titles now works for the MLB
Network and uh MLB Network have Yankees
and the Jays tonight that will be uh
nationally Al thanks for joining us on
short notice uh if you're on that blue
jays staff as you once were
what would the pitching strategy be for
Aaron judge
uh fastball is up and then sliders down
and away don't hang anything he is uh
you know had an amazing year Triple
Crown year and uh there would be no
doubt how I would approach it nor would
I think some of my old pitching coaches
and managers I just heard that that
little sound bite you shown the or
listened to
um no I I and it's not a stubbornness
again and it's not a Bravado tough guy
thing either it's it's just it's just
playing the game right and um while
there's competition it's the most
awesome Gladiator syndrome aspect of all
sports Mano Amano you stand on the mound
you're facing the guy with a bat I'm
gonna try to exploit a weakness and I'm
going to do it but to just randomly
throw four balls uh you know errantly
way out of the Zone specially early in
the game now it would it make sense if
it's a 2-2 game three to two game tight
game and I got Aaron judge up in the
seventh or eighth inning probably dumb
uh to give him anything good to pit hit
but yeah a hundred percent would go
after it but I also wonder this though
Al the pit the hitters behind Aaron
judge haven't picked him up so when they
walk him they don't do anything where
you go well we got a pitch to judge
because the guy behind him is killing us
I wouldn't be pitching to Aaron judge if
I'm the Blue Jays because he's the guy
I'm gonna worry about beating me I'm not
worried about the guy behind him so how
much does that factor into your pitching
philosophy or game plan yeah no the
great point and that that that becomes
dumb right if if what you just described
everybody else behind Aaron judge is is
a little eager or High School hitter
then why would you pitch to you know the
MVP so that's that's one facet which I
haven't bored down on every single game
and every single box score uh in the
last uh however many he hasn't hit his
home run yeah um as to who's doing what
I know they won last night but no that
that that plays into it look I I think
mostly and it happened to me I remember
too distinct it was in 98 when when
McGuire was down the stretch and it was
I think it was either early September or
late August and we were at all Bush
Stadium
um pitched against Mack everybody's
packed house I threw a ball at the place
booed the Umpire called the strike the
place booed like everybody just wanted
to hit a home run and it was cool I mean
I'll be honest with you I'm a little
nutty anyway but I thought I was like oh
this is awesome
um he didn't hit a home run I might have
gotten hit I think I struck him out a
couple times actually but it was just
the I I because I was a little crazy I
just I liked it I I enjoyed it I
remember
um I also remember when uh when Bonds
hit his 70 what did he hit 73 I don't
know number I guess 73. it was that it
was at Shea Stadium we were out of it
Barry was you know pushing it was
definitely in September place was packed
um and I pitched the Barry again it
might have been stupid but uh I just
I enjoyed it I I thought it was the
coolest thing and his last at bat he
didn't get he didn't get a home run that
night but his last at bat I think I hung
a curveball or something he hits a ball
in the right center field at Shea flies
in the third base and Barry uh he looks
over at me and like kind of in a in kind
of a cute way with Barry whatever he
looks at me he kind of like heading on
to the week he winks and he's like hey
man thanks and I you know thought about
I was like yeah I want to walk you I
want to strike your ass out that that
was my thinking so
um you know maybe a little different I I
would go after listen if I if I was
picked tonight in Toronto I I would go
after Aaron I would be smart about it
and my whole job is about executing
quality pets that that was my Mantra
when I met Harvey Dorfman the mental
game of baseball in 1991 and yeah fifth
sixth seventh inning in a tight game
probably will pitch around a little bit
yeah I understand the Blue Jays not
pitching to him because they're in the
playoff race I understand the Red Sox
because of the Rivalry but you've got
Baltimore and Texas coming up
those three teams that are not factoring
independent race they should well it
also too also too then you know then it
becomes a command issue I was just
watching highlights this morning and
watching the Nationals some young kids
that are pitching against the kunion boy
oh boy you couldn't center cut those
pitches any any better and I you know I
feel for I've been there you know to
give up home runs and hard hit balls but
you know you have a guy that's hot the
braids are hot and you you know you got
to be better than that so on top of what
you just said now Baltimore had a really
nice year uh surprise a lot of people
but you if you have young arms on the
mound that really can't command it
um he's gonna get mistakes and mistakes
you know in the case of you know over
the heart of the plate
we're talking now lighter Major League
Baseball Network analysts of course
former pitcher he won the world series
three times yeah I'm just curious if
pitcher's not pitching to Aaron judge
are actually changing history by
choosing not to compete with him
perhaps uh we I don't know if we could
get in the mind of it but if I Bear Down
on the game
um I know we got it nationally and then
uh you know of course to be on yes but I
could generally tell if a guy is
throwing a non-competitive pitch that
just looks like he's purposely trying to
throw it out out of the zone as opposed
to with conviction and intent behind it
um that that's pretty obvious if you've
thrown thousands of pitches
um
so I don't know I I guess we got to
start bearing down on how how these
pitchers just don't look like they're
competing or not I I'm not going to
believe that Dan I I I think there's a
lot of pictures that are would accept
this challenge I I hear I'll give you an
example so that you're a Big Mac at 98.
so I later play with Steve tracks on
love tracks uh he was with the Cubs at
the time and he gave up Max uh 60 second
home run right yeah in in Bush and to
this day I think if you talk to tracks
he's still pissed yes yes he is and I
thought about it I didn't want to be
disrespectful to see tracksuit but I'm
like you know what it was kind of cool
like you get up 60 second like you know
I know you made a couple All-Stars and
all that but like not that you tried to
give up the home run but you know I gave
up a lot of home runs you know it's like
all right so you gave up 60 seconds I
would not be timid about being the guy
who gave up the Home Run not at all oh
so you wouldn't care about going down in
history
no
no forever you know giving up uh
yeah thank God yeah but I don't know if
he wore it as a you know uh
a badge of honor there yeah no no no I'm
not now again I'm not saying like I want
to be that guy no but I'm not going to
shy away from not competing
um yeah so maybe is that stubborn is it
dumb maybe it depends on well you've got
the three World Series rings too that
helps
and I don't know when to wear them dance
um great to talk to you as always
thank you thanks for calling in all
right buddy stay well that's Al leiter
MLB network analyst